Test
Testing testing testingTest
>> Good evening, ladies and
gentlemen.  Welcome to the
Library of Congress' celebration
of Women's History Month.  It's
such a pleasure.  Welcome to our
live stream audience out there,
welcome to the Library of
Congress, the
historic Collid ge
auditorium.
My name is Ari Ar an
anna, and a literally advisor
to the Library of Congress.
Dr.
Carla Hayden, our Librarian of
Congress, the first woman
Librarian of Congress in the
history of
the United States of
America --
[Applause]
-- is home with a stress
throat.  So you're going to have
to
deal with me.  But she sends all
her best.
And a big greeting
to you on Women's History Month.
So here is the big question that
we're posing today.
Now, you heard the names.
Right?  Of John Glen.
And Allen Alan
shepherd and Neil Armstrong.
What about Katherine Johnson and
Dorothy Vaughn and Mary Jackson
and Barbara Holly?  We're here
to throw a very bright light on
a wonderful book and a wonderful
movie.  "Hidden Figures" is the
remarkable story of three
pioneering African American
women at NACA, and as it
happens,
that story sits smack dab in the
middle of some of the most
defining moments of the 20th
century.  The Cold War.  The
space race, the civil rights
movement,
and the ongoing quest for
gender equality.
Though they did the same work as
whites, hired at the time,
these women were kept apart, not
only in gender, segregated
offices, but in racially
segregated offices, at NACA's
Langley
campus
.  Despite the hardships of
working
under strict Jim Crowe
laws, they went on to help with
in the space race.
By now, "Hidden Figures" has
been published as an adult book
and a children's book so a
universe of young girls can be
inspired by this story of grit,
grace, perseverance.
Now, I'm told there's a doll
even of Katherine Johnson, which
is amazing.
I'll get that for my
grandchildren.  And to let you
know "Hidden Figures" will be on
sale after this program and
Margo will be signing her books.
Just last week, Margot Lee
Shetterly published a wonderful
essay for Women's History Month
from the Library of Congress
magazine.  If you don't know
this magazine, you should.  On
the
back page is this wonderful
essay in which Margo says: When
I
was growing up in Hampton,
Virginia, the face of science
was
brown, like mine.  My dad was a
NASA lifer.  A career Langley
research -- career -- sorry.
A career Langley research
scientist, who became an
internationally respected
climate
expert.
Five of my father's seven
siblings were engineers or
technologists.
My father's best friend was an
aeronautical
engineer.
There were mathematicians in our
church and sonic boom
experts in my mother's sorority.
Why don't we know more about
these people, she writes in big
capital letters?
Well, lest you don't know enough
about the person asking that
question, let me tell you a
little about her.  Margot Lee
Shetterly was born in Hampton,
Virginia.  Her father was a
research scientist as I said at
NASA.
Her mother was an English
professor at the historically
black Hampton University.  She
graduated from University of
Virginia.  After college she
worked
in New York and worked several
years in investment banking,
J.P.
J.Morgon and then Merrill Lynch.
In 2014 she sold the book and
film rights to "Hidden
Figures".
And even as a proposal, not even
a manuscript, it was
optioned
optioned by the other guest
we're going to hear from
tonight,
Donna Gigliotti of Levantine
films.
Margo is also the founder of the
Human Computer Project, an
effort to recover the names and
accomplishments of all the women
who worked as computers,
mathematicians, scientists, and
engineers at NASA and its
predecessor NACA from the 1930s
to the
1980s.
And who is Donna Gigliotti?
The woman who brought us the
movie "Hidden Figures" on the
big screen?
She's an American
film producer best known for
producing the Academy Award
winning
film Shakespeare in Love.
And she also produced the
Reader.
She Worked with Martin SCORSESE
on Riding Bull.  She also worked
on Devil in a Blue Dress.
She produced "Hidden Figures",
which stars Taraji Henson,
Octavia
sponsor, Janelle Monae, and
Kevin Costner.  It won
dozens of award, best picture,
best screen play, and best
supporting actress.
So remind you of the film, my
colleague has produced a short
video and we'd like to share it
with you now.  It's not meant to
be bio-graphical or documentary
in any way.
It's a tribute to
the African American women who
despite great odds played a
ground breaking role in American
scientific progress.
>> We need a mathematician that
can look beyond the numbers.
>> I never knew there were
women working behind the scenes
in NACA in the space race.
>> They had really next-level
jobs.
>> We're putting a human on top
of a missile shooting into
space and it's never been done
before.
>> These women changed the
game.
>> It's wonderful to play a
strong woman, but they have
vulnerable
vulnerabilityies.
>> It felt like it to me, too.
>> These ordinary women does
ex extraordinary things.
>> It's crunch time.
In 14 days, astronauts will be
here
for training.
Everything we do can matter to
their wives and
children and the whole damn
country.
>> "Hidden Figures" is about
how black and white, men and
women, put a man in space.
That's empowerment.
>> It's getting a little hot in
here.
[Applause]
>> Wonderful. Now, ladies
and gentlemen, I'd like you to
welcome the award winning,
wonderful
writer, Margo Lee
Shetterly, and the award winning
marvelous film producer Donna
Gigliotti.
[Applause]
>> So glad to have you here at
the Library of Congress.
Thank you for making the trip
Donna and Margo.  Wonderful to
have you here.  I want to start
we were talking back stage about
exactly how this movie came to
be made.
And I, in fact, had in
my notes that it had come after
you had read the manuscript,
but, no, that's not the story.
Tell us the story, Margo and
Donna.
>> Well, I started working on
"Hidden Figures", what would
become "Hidden Figures", in
2010.  And started doing
research.
I grew up in Hampton, Virginia.
I knew Katherine Johnson from
the time I was a child.  My dad
worked at NASA.  And anyway,
started working on the book.
2013 started, had written a book
proposal, found an agent, who
then sold it to HarperCollins to
be published in 2014.
Really kind of unbeknownst to
me.  I
wasn't very clear.  Maybe we can
talk about how it actually
happened, because it's still
kind of a mystery.
My book proposal ended up in the
ends
of someone named Donna
Gigliotti.  I remember being in
Hampton, Virginia and getting a
phone call and pulled into the
parking
lot of the Food Lion if
anybody is from Virginia, that's
my favorite part of the story.
>> That specificity tells
she's an author.
[Laughter]
>> I pulled into the Virginia
Food Lion and Donna introduced
herself and she said on that
first phone call, we're going to
make a movie of this book.  I
said, well, you know, it's not a
book yet.
[Laughter]
Which didn't exist at the time.
It was a book proposal.  And
yet, this very intrepid,
multiply awarded, gifted, film
maker
had a vision for this 55-page
book proposal.  And that was in
--
that was four years ago.  It was
this time four years ago.
>> And the part she's
leaving out about this story
that I
said to her while she was in the
Food Lion, "And we're going to
go to the Oscars together."
[Applause]
>> On the first phone call in
the
parking lot of the Food
Lion.  That's what happened.
>> Incredible.
>> It's nice but it sounds
fairy land and all of that, but
the truth was that Margo, she
was onto something with that
book
proposal that I could feel.  I
knew it.
It was in the
zeitgeist.  It was about women
not getting their due, African
American women not getting their
due.  It was about math.  It
was about space.
It was a confluence of things
that really -- I
never doubted that it would be
successful.  Because you could
feel it in the zeitgeist.  She
tapped into it.
>> This was even before the
whole mania of code girls.  That
didn't actually happen until the
following year.
>> No, it didn't.
What I clearly remember is
shortly
optioning the book proposal,
Google came out and they finally
came clean on what the
composition was of their
workforce.
>> Right.
>> And it was astonishing
because it was largely male and
largely white.
And I thought, okay, now, I know
that this is --
it's in the zeitgeist.
It was that, coupled with maybe
eight or
nine months later, after coming
out, and the confluence was
undeniable, actually.
>> Wonderful. Wonderful
story.  I'm going to back away
and
ask you about, for the young
people in the audience who are
watching out there on live and
out there on live stream, what
was it about your
views that brought you to this
place or that made you what you
are today?
Margo, what was it about you
that actually -- was it
the drive there?
How did this happen that you are
who you are
today?  Given the child that you
were then?
>> MARGOT: A lot of it really
does have to do with my
parents and the community that I
grew up in and the people that
I grew up around.
As I mentioned, my father worked
at NASA.  My
mother was an English professor
at Hampton University.  And
there was this expectation.  I
mean I think I finally redeemed
myself with my dad.  He wanted
me to become an engineer.  I
didn't.
[Laughter]
So I think I've kind of finally
done enough to redeem myself
with that.  But from the time I
was little, we would go and see
my mom at work over at Hampton
University.
We'd see James
Baldwin and Maya Angelou and all
these moving writers and so
forth that would come to Hampton
University.
We would go get this computer
paper.  This is dating me in a
big way.  You would not believe
the huge paper that would get
produced for these calculations
they were doing back in the 70s.
The thing that was so wonderful
about that was being exposed at
this very young age to this
entire very wide spectrum of
different kinds of people,
different backgrounds, women,
who
were working at NASA, like my
mother, and who were professors
like my mother,
and there was never this idea
that there was anything off
limits.
And from a particularly young
age, and to see these
women doing these jobs of
scientists, and you kind of take
it
for granted.  When that is the
floor, it makes it easy to say,
well, I don't want to do that.
I want to do something else.
Which I wanted to walk on wall
Wall Street.  That seemed like
the new
frontier to me.
But having both that very
nurturing
in terms of my apparent parents,
but also the community around
us, this is really a love letter
to my childhood.
>> Absolutely. How about you,
Donna, how did you get to
where you are?
>> DONNA: It's a very
similar story.  I grew up in
Upstate
New York in a little tiny town.
Essentially, it was a
tremendous amount of support
from my family and the
community.
It really was my mother.  I'm
old.  I was born in 1954.  And
it
was my mother always saying you
can do whatever it is that you
want to do.
And, you know, she was of a
generation and maybe
she was a little frustrated and
put that all onto me.  I always
tell the story, this is true, I
was 18 years old before I
realized I was not the prettiest
or the smartest girl in the
world because she told me that
the entire time.
[Laughter]
It was astonishing to me that
that was not the case.
[Laughter]
So mom.
>> Oh, moms are great.
>> Moms.
Women's History Month.  Let's
hear it for the
moms.
[Applause]
>> Thanks be to them.
How was it, Margo, that you
actually came upon this subject?
You said and you have written in
this magazine and said many
times that it was that culture
that you grew up in, but,
actually, stumbling on this
actual story, how did that
happen?
>> MARGOT: Well, the thing
that's really great about it is
this story has very much to do
with the most important men in
my
life.
My husband and I had gone home
Christmas 2010 to visit my
parents and we ran into a woman
who was somebody we had known
from church growing up.  She's
my Sunday school teacher.  And
my
dad started talking about her.
She was 96, I think, and had
worked her whole career as a
computer in the West area
computing
group.
I didn't quite know it.  There's
so many things you hear as a
kid, you kind of just tune out,
whatever it's not not important
to me, whatever, but anyway, it
turned into this entire
conversation with me kind of
listening, between my dad and my
husband.  And my husband looked
at me like, oh, my God, I can't
believe this.  What?  I've never
heard this story before.
And I had heard this story.
I had known these women, but
never really took the time to
think,
well, jeez, why were there
black women mathematicians there
in the 1950s?
Why is my now
96-year-old Sunday school
teacher -- like, how did this
all
happen?  It was really a moment
for me of seeing something with
fresh eyes, something that we
had really taken for granted
growing up in the Hampton.
Because they were just normal.
They
got up and went to work.  They
went to PTA meeting.  We saw
them
in the Food Lions
[Laughter]
It was normal but yet an
extraordinary thing they'd done
and
an extraordinary history there.
That was really the beginning
of it.
My husband is a writer, and he's
like, "This is a great book.
"
That was really the beginning of
it.
>> Let's hear it for good
husbands.
[Applause]
>> But you knew Katherine
Johnson.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And what was she like? The
version we had was the
version that's in your book,
which is very vivid, and then
this
vision of a young Katherine
Johnson, you must have known
her, of
course, when she was older?
>> MARGOT: I remember her
when I was a kid.  It was right
around the time she had retired
from NASA.  She was one of these
extremely active in the
community.  She was the
president of the
local chapter of the sorority.
She was just an impeccable
person, tall with a pant suit.
Not the kind of person that you
wanted to kind of -- you wanted
to be on the right side.  I mean
she's funny and gracious, but
very serious.  As a kid, you
know
the people who are very serious.
[Laughter]
You do not jump around and
play around or whatever.
And she was part of the
community.  You know?
And during the course of the
research for the book, I
realized just how much had been
written about her.  The first
article I found on Katherine
Johnson was published in I think
late 1959, early 1960.
So two years before John Glenn's
flight.
She had this sort of mythology
grow up around her in Hampton,
Virginia, but she was an active
part of the community.  She was
part of a group of people.  Even
as people knew about the
achievements, she was still part
of a group.  You know?  She did
not stand apart from the rest of
the people there in the
community.
>> Do you think that she
realized what part in history
she
had played?
I mean she was aware of the
importance of being a
woman, being an African American
woman, being a scientist, and
being at that place in time, in
NASA, when this was going down,
it was a very big deal?
You know the space race was
huge.  And
Ury Gagarin had gotten up into
space and we needed to get up
there.
Did she seem like the sort of
person who was aware of her
importance?
Or was she sort of dismissive
and not necessarily
--
>> Well, I think she and the
other women were very aware of
their roles in the mission.  And
what they had done.  And what
they had contributed to the
mission and to the work.
I think the awareness of history
is something that takes
time.  And I think that's
something that, now, not just
she, but
all of these other women, and
the women of code girls, for
example.  I mean there's so many
stories about women having done
these things.
So history is recognizing it.
But if you talk to these
women, I mean Katherine Johnson,
I was just doing my job.
>> Exactly. Very modest in
a lot of ways about her role in
the entire process.
>> How was she at the Academy
Awards?  Because she's 100
years old now, or about to be?
>> This year she'll be 100.
>> Yeah.
>> She was -- well, we think
she was excited, because her
daughter told us she was
excited.  But she wasn't having
any of
it.  You know?  It was like,
yep, I'm going to go Academy
Awards.  Yep.
Yes, we had a dress made for her
and she went through
fittings.
I think she was a little
befuddled by all the hoopla
around the meeting.
I remember when Taraji went down
to meet her.  I don't know
if you watch Empire but Taraji
Plays Cookie.
She Was in Full
Cookie mode.
[Laughter]
I don't think Katherine
Johnson knew what to do with
Taraji
in that room.
But ultimately, they found
the place.  Taraji, if she were
here, would tell you how
important that meeting was,
because she
got to actually understand.
She listened a lot to tapes of
Katherine so she could get the
syntax right.  There's a lot of
research that went into that
performance.  But Katherine was
a
little like, "Whoa, what's
happening here?"
[Laughter]
>> I have this picture.
Picture this.  You have a writer
who has sold in sup
proposal, so you haven't written
a book, but
you've put this proposal up for
publication.  It's been bought.
It's also been bought for a
film.  And the film is turning
while
you're actually writing the
book.  Imagine that.  And I'm
imagining you making the film on
the basis of -- I mean it was a
50 page proposal.  This is not
five pages.  Right?  It was a
substantial proposal.  So you
had a lot to work with.
But the picture I have of you
is these two women scrambling
to produce.
>> You have no idea.
Essentially it went like this:
Margo,
have you finished the book yet
in have you finished the book?
The movie is going to be out.
Have you finished the book?
[Laughter]
>> And I'm like, oh, my God,
I have to finish the book.  And
then I'm like, there's a script!
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
I'm looking at the book.
Everything has to be -- I'm like
I'm
writing this book and it take
place from 1943 to 1949 with an
epilogue that goes into the 70s.
How come this movie is only
going to be up to 1962?  Which
was ultimately a very good
decision.  But it was so
interesting for me to do
something that
I had never done before.
And to go through this
simultaneously
another experience, based on
this thing that I'd never done
before, and do that, too.
It was -- I learned so much.
>> DONNA: The great thing is
we also came out of it as
friends, even though I was
torturing her everyday.
>> MARGOT: I got tortured.
[Laughter]
>> DONNA: We really did some
out of it as very good friends,
which was a gift.
And she looked terrific coming
down that red
carpet at the Oscars.
>> MARGOT: It was a great
experience.  And the thing I
really appreciated about the
movie, is Donna came in with
this
vision of this story and these
women, and the importance of
these women, and then you really
made it your mission to get the
best people.  And the people who
understood what it meant and
what it could mean, to girls, to
women, to African Americans, to
scientists.
You know, it was to amazing to
go in, in the Food
Lion parking lot and to come out
at the Oscars.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
>> MARGOT: But to come away
with the experience of having
worked with such talented,
committed, interesting people
along
the way.  It was fantastic.
>> DONNA: When I say there was
a
kind of kizmit going on,
what she's talking about, one of
the people that was absolutely
integral to the whole process
was Pharell Williams.  It and
happened almost by accident.
His partner is a woman who came
in
to
to see me just in general and
she said what kind of things are
you working on?
And I said, oh, I'm developing
this script.
It's called "Hidden Figures".  I
told her what it was about.
She was silent through the whole
entire thing.  At the end of my
pitch, she said, Pharell will do
anything to be a part of that.
And I said, why is that?  She
said, well, you know, he grew
up in Hampton, Virginia.  Who
knew?
Very involved in the STEM
initiative.  Great.  And he's
obsessed with space.
[Laughter]
Okay.  Check, check, check.
But in Hollywood, people say
stuff
like that, "Oh, he'll do
anything to be a part of it."
Well, great.
The next day my assistant coming
running into my office and
he's shaking and he's like,
"Phearell Williams is on the
phone."
It's true.  He was on the
phone the next day.  Because
he's
southern he called me Ms. Donna.
He said, Ms. Donna, I will do
anything to be a part of this
project.  And I was like, okay,
good, good, good.
He said I'm coming to New York
in another week.  Can we meet?
I say, sure, no problem.
A week passes and I go to
meet him.  I said there are so
many
elements of this movie that are
so important to me.  What can I
do on it?
I said, well, you're Pharell
Williams.  We think you
can do the music.
[Laughter]
So I said, I think you can do
the music.  He said, "Good,
good, good, because I've been
working on some stuff."
[Laughter]
Margo has not finished the book,
and Pharell has written the
music.
[Laughter]
He said, here, I'll play it for
you.  He put it onto the
speakers and I said, great.
This is the best story.  That's
why
I'm telling it.  He got to
another song and he said I only
have
the instrumentals.
I was like, all right, dude,
it's fine.  You
know?
He said, no, no, no, it's really
good.  He said I'll just
have to sing it for you.
[Laughter]
I kid you not.
If he was sitting next to me he
would recount
this exactly as I did.  He sat
on the couch and he sang the
song
to me.  I said, "You got the
job."
[Laughter]
But having people like that,
Octavia Spencer, she walks on
water.
Not only is she a magnificent
actor, but the first time
she came to see me, she said, I
don't know what part to play; do
I want to play Dorothy or Mary?
So it was a very special
group of people we had around
us.
>> Absolutely magical. Of
course, it ended up being
nominated for best screen play.
So something was going on with
the writing process, as well.
Tell us about the research
for the book.  We're talking
about
interviews and neighbors and all
of that.
>> MARGOT: You know, it was so
interesting, this sort of
chain of knowledge.  You know,
what fact would lead to the
other.  The first interview, of
course, was with Katherine
Johnson.  And Katherine Johnson
mentioned a number of people in
that first interview.
One of them was Dorothy Vaughn
whose name
I'd never heard of.  Dorothy
Vaughn actually left, retired,
shortly after my father started
working there.  And she
mentioned Mary Jackson, who
actually I did know, because she
had
worked with my father in the
early part of his career.  She
mentioned Christine Dardin who
is in the book but not in the
movie because she went to school
with and is part of the next
generation of engineers.
Every time I got a clue, I
would have to go off and
condition
of like an archeologist sort of
excavate the information.  The
information was there.  It was
really there.  But it had never
been colated into one place.  A
lot of work in the National
Archives, the NASA History
Office, and
the NASA Langley History
Office were particularly useful.
Interviews with the women's
children and colleagues, there
was so much information.  And
then, really, this wonderful
opportunity to go into the math
and
the science and the engineering
itself.  And spending so much
time with the actual reports
that these women worked on.
And it was such an incredible,
like being in a time machine.
Every morning I'd get up and
have my research task.
It was like I'd jump in the time
machine.
And I went back to 1943.
And sometimes it was about Aaron
airplane, because they were
working on airplanes before
spaceships.
Sometimes it was about the civil
rights legislation that
opened up public schools and
public accommodations and all
these
other things.
Sometimes it was about women and
how women made breakthroughs
in World War II and such.
So I got this incredible
research.
And it was like the people came
back to life.  I wish I had
known Dorothy Vaughn.  That's
one of my great regrets through
this.
But I feel as if I have gotten
to know her.
From having spent so much time
with the documents and the
people who knew her.
So it was overwhelming.
The hardest part was wrestling
this information into a
narrative.
And doing it in a way that
the people lead the story.
That it wasn't just 1963 John
Glenn did this.
It was always about these women,
a story they knew.
A story where they got to be the
protagonisted.
And that it was always a human
story, that it always
connected back to them as
people, and
not just the historical
facts.
>> My impression is a lot of
women went into science,
correct me if I'm wrong, went
into science during the war,
when
the colleges and universities,
the men had all gone to war.
So more women went in.
More people of different
races went in to those
educational
spots that were suddenly open.
>> Absolutely.
>> Is this what happens in the
process of these women's
lives, that they were given
opportunities by virtue of the
circumstance of the war?
>> MARGOT: It was. World
War II transformed our country
in
so many different ways.
Legally, there was an executive
order that forbade
discrimination in the civil
service, and that was the thing
that
opened the door for these women.
But then just supply and
demand.  The men were off in the
war.
And these women were really
good at math.
I mean they were math
teachers, most of them, before
they
came there.
But
they were exceptionally talented
mathematicians.  Once
that door opened, those women
took a seat, and that changed
our
country.
>> There is a wonderful scene
in the
movie where
that
outrage is clear.  It actually,
as I understand it from the
book, Katherine Johnson was not
doing
the 800-meter hike.  She
was actually using the bathroom
right there, and nobody there
said anything, because she was
such a proud, elegant --
obviously, nobody is going to
say anything to her.
So there are differences in
the movie and the reality and
the
movie.
Tell us about your decision to
sort
of conflate some people
into one, for instance, and
change the time a little bit,
and
those decisions which had to be
made, obviously.
>> DONNA: They too do, do,
because movies fall into
structure and
you need a dramatic arc.  It is
true that the bathrooms had been
desegregated at NASA before the
time period.
>> Everybody knew that
happened,?
>> DONNA: Margot's father was
very adamant about it.  He
said, "It's not true." But I
said," It's the movies."
[Laughter]
I take full responsibility
for
putting Katherine Johnson in
Mission Control at the end of
the movie.  That's not true.
There was no woman in Mission
Control.  It had to be another
ten
years before there was a woman
in that room.  What would you
have done?
You have to have a moment of
triumph for the
character on some level.  You
kind of have to take those
leaps.
Which is which it says "inspired
by a true story" on the front
of the movie.  It doesn't say
"true story.
" We did have to take
those leaps.
>> Ultimately true, you will
say.
>> DONNA: Right.
>> Let's talk about this
culture -- the culture in NASA
has
obviously changed.  We've now
had African American astronauts,
and African American
administrators, deputy
administrator, chief
deputy administrator, chief
scientist.  Right.  How is that
progress?  How did it happen?
Was it tough going?  Did the
doors fling open at some point?
How did that progress?
>> MARGOT: The interesting
thing about NASA, as a
government
entity, it was always more
progressive than the aircraft
industries and the contractors
and things like that.
I think that's sort of the
reasons why I was able to grow
up
and see this critical mass of
women, of all backgrounds, who
were working there.
My father working there, it was
a more open work environment.
You know, the doors were, you
know, more open to different
kinds of people.
And so I think in that sense,
NASA,
you know, the DNA was
sort of set, way back then.
I do think that there is a
direct relationship between what
those women were able to do and
their accomplishments.
And the fact that this agency
eventually had, you know, an
African American administrator.
Several female center chiefs,
African American center
directors.
So, you know, I think when we
talk about sort of the
implications, the larger
implications for this story and
for
organizations today, I do think
that when you put that into the
organizational DNA and you make
it possible for talented people,
regardless of who they are, to
go as far as their account will
take them and contribute to the
organization, then you get the
people at the top who, you know,
are also able to do that.
And if you want to have
CEO-suite level people who are
diverse and female and look like
America, well, you've got to
start with that base level DNA
at the organization.  I think
that's one of the stories,
important take-aways from this
story.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely.
And I am sure that you heard
from people out there how your
book and this story and the film
and the whole sort of composite
has inspired people, young
women, girls, to go into STEM
courses, which is so important
in
this country today.
What sort of reaction have you
been getting in that realm
from educators?
>> DONNA: We joke about
this, that "Hidden Figures"
exposes
a magical word.  I had something
to do with "Hidden Figures".
It's almost more than the book
and the film.  It feels like a
movement on some level.
And the thing that's exciting
for the
both of us, I think, is
that the -- I think this is
true, that one of the most
important
ways that you can shift the
culture is to portray women or
people of color in a way that is
surprising and new.
And what is engendered from that
is a new way of thinking.
And that's what we've seen in
terms of Black Girls Code and
it goes on and on and on.
Remind me what you said over
dinner about India.
>> MARGOT: "Hidden Figures" has
become a term.  I have this
Google alert that sets up for
"Hidden Figures" and I just pick
up all the articles that mention
"Hidden Figures".  It's
everything from the local
association wherever in Virginia
is
going to be screening the movie
to, like, this event will turn
up or whatever.
The "Hidden Figures" of India's
agriculture
industry, or something.  You
know?
This is something that people --
I mean talking about the
movement, people are like, "I
knew there was more than I was
being told.  I knew there were
people out there doing these
different things.  I didn't know
how to find them.  I didn't
know where to find them."
I think that's the energy.
Like, oh, my God, I see the
success.
And now I have a completer idea
of the world and what
I might do in the world.
And the girls, I don't know if I
told you this, I got this
tweet last year, and this mom
was like, "I have this daughter
who is 9 years old and in the
fourth grade and she's very math
phobic and she tried so," and
she tried
so hard to get her to -- it
wasn't that
she was bad at math but she had
a phobia, a block.  She saw the
movie.
She said her daughter said to
her on the eve of a math test,
the numbers are going into my
head just like Dorothy Vaughn.
[Laughter]
And you say to yourself, wow.
That is humbling to hear a
story like that.
>> That's wonderful. That is
really wonderful.
We want to open it up to
questions from the audience.  We
have two mics that are going to
roam.  Anybody who would like
that, we welcome our your
questions.  I would just ask
that you
please stand when you ask a
question and that you hold the
mic,
speak into the mic, so that we
can actually hear you and record
you.  Any questions out there?
Over here.  Okay.
Wait for the mic, please.  Thank
you.
>> Thank you for wonderful
presentation.  Very inspiring
for
all of us, women and for young
people.
I just want to say about your
idea about "Hidden Figures" and
you wrote about in mathematics
and NASA and so on.  Why not to
go further?
A lot of hidden figures in other
industries and
other places.
Sometimes women really don't
have a voice.  Maybe
to go further.  It's just an
invitation.  It's just an idea
to
discuss more about women's roles
in different, other places,
other industries, and so on.
Thank you.
.
>> DONNA: That's a good
idea.  Maybe you should consider
volume two and three.  Thank you
very much for that.
[Laughter]
>> Other questions? Thank you.
Right here?  Oh, over
there.  Sorry.
>> I'm just wondering in the
course of writing the book and
gathering all the research, what
personal transformation did you
undergo during the process?
>> MARGOT: Personal
transformation over the course
of
writing the book?  Honestly, the
biggest transformation is that
I am now a professional writer.
[Laughter] [applause] I'm a
full-time writer.  I've done a
lot of the different things.  I
was an investment banker and
worked in the internet industry.
This is the best job I've ever
had.  I'm working on a new book.
It's very exciting.  I've gotten
to know people like Donna.  And
I've come to look at history in
a different way.  I've gotten to
know so much about our country's
history.  I've gotten to know
people who have influenced the
course of history that have sort
of disappeared from view.  That,
to me, this thing of being a
writer and the privilege of
getting to do that, as a
full-time
job, is phenomenal.  I'm very
grateful for that.
>> So Margot, can you tell us
about your book?
>> MARGOT: or will that
hex it if you do?
>> MARGOT: It's not a hex.
During the research, which was
the wonderful time machine I got
to
visit people in 1943 and
1957 and this sort of thing, I
really felt like that's what it
was like.  I just kept coming
across these
amazing amazing stories of
people like Katherine Johnson
who were just doing their jobs
and
making differences and we didn't
know who they were.  I decided
if I had a chance to write a
different book, I had a little
file
of stories I wanted to work on.
And sort of the hidden figures
series, nonfiction, as I come to
think of it, that these
stories, African American
protagonists, same time period,
because I'm really obsessed with
that time period, really, like
mid 30s to the '70s, totally
obsessed with that time period,
who
were real protagonists and did
interesting things.
The next book takes place in
Baltimore and it
has to do with
businesspeople.  [Applause]
>> Very good. Over here?
>> Hi. This is a question
for Donna.  Do you -- did you
ever consider doing this as a
documentary, given that it was a
nonfiction book?  And why or why
not?
>> DONNA: No. I didn't
consider it doing as a doc.  I
thought it would have a wider
audience if it was a fictional
film or a feature film.  But a
doc would be interesting.  Just
because there are things that
we, you know, the specifics in
the
film that we couldn't really
dive into.  Are you a
documentary
film maker?
[Laughter] You missed an
opportunity in making that
doc.
[Laughter]
>> Anybody else? We had a
question down here, I believe.
Okay.
>> Sorry if I missed it. Can
you tell me again how you two
met?
Can you remind us how you two
>> DONNA: How the two of us
met?
I called her up in the --
>> In the parking lot.
>> DONNA: In the parking lot of
the Food Lion.  That was it.
I read her proposal and I said
to her agent, "I must speak to
this woman," and I got the phone
number and dialed it.
>> So it was through the agent.
>> DONNA: It really was.
But it's been a happy story
between us.
>> Very happy story.
>> Over here.
>> Hi.
This question is for Margot.
>> You're next, okay?
>> One thing that really struck
me was you talking about
your book being a love letter to
Hampton, Virginia.  I went to
Tuskegee University.
Our islands of excellence where
we do see
people that look like us.  Where
you do see examples of black
success.  That makes such a huge
difference when you go forth in
the world.
I guess my question is, HBCU
seems to be on the
decline in some ways now.
The towns around them aren't
doing as
well.  Not as many students want
to go.  I wonder what that
means for the future?  Where do
the next Katherine Johnsons come
from and where is the community
that's going to nurture them and
tell them they're they can do
anything?  Especially, to use
your word,
the zeitgeist of the time?
>> MARGOT: I think that's a
good question.  There were so
many products of Black colleges.
I was driving around Baltimore
today doing research for the
book, and Morgan State is there.
There are new buildings and
obviously there's a lot of
energy.
Another university that's there
has less energy.  There are
issues that are facing many,
many institutions of higher
education, not just Black
colleges, but a lot of the Black
colleges are really feeling
these issues.
I went to the University of
Virginia.
So my parents went to
Black colleges.  I didn't.  So
doing this research, it was just
an amazing, full panoramic view
of the support and excellence
and concentration of talent,
particularly during that time
period.
But I think, for example,
Spelman is a tremendous success
story.
When we talk about the
intersection of Black colleges
and STEM, they're doing
extremely well.
I think Spelman College
sends more Black women to STEM
Ph.D. programs than any other
school in the country.  I think
that may be true.  You know, and
I think this is also an issue at
women's colleges, which was
another huge feeder for these
jobs at NASA and many other
jobs.
So I think that is a really,
really great question.
And, you know, the HBCU's I feel
were another character in
this book, along with the Black
newspapers, another hugely
important part of this legacy.
And, you know, I consider myself
very much the beneficiary
and recipient of that legacy.
>> No doubt.
>> Yeah. We have a question
here, I believe.
>> What did you feel like were
when you wrote a book or a
film?
>> MARGOT: What did I feel
like when I wrote the book?
>> What did you feel like
when you
wrote the book or the
film?
>> MARGOT: What did I feel
like?  Wow.  No, this is a
really
good question.
>> We all felt something when
we read the book.
>> MARGOT: Well, you know, I
have to say, the thing is it
was really hard.  [Laughter]
It was both really, really
enjoyable and I loved the
research, and I loved the
writing, but it was really hard.
It
was hard.  It was hard.
And a lot of it was hard because
I
wished I could get up in the
morning and write with at
8:00 o'clock with a cup of
coffee.  Graham Green supposedly
did
that.  But you know what?  I
waste an entire day and I don't
really start writing until it's
like 11:30 at night.  And that's
really painful.  I wish it were
different, but it's not.
>> 11:30. In the morning?
>> MARGOT: No, at night.
>> DONNA: Oh.
[Laughter]
>> MARGOT: The most
productive time is 11:30 at
night until
4 in the morning.
>> People don't realize a
lot of writing when you're
writing
a book is up here, you're
thinking it.
And you could be doing
the laundry and you're still
working it through somehow.
When
you actually sit down, you've
already done a lot of things.
So
it's okay.
>> MARGOT: Okay.
But the other thing I thought
was I really
felt an obligation to really get
the stories of these women
right.  I wasn't writing about
myself.  I was writing about
them.  So I felt a tremendous
amount of pressure to represent
their stories in a way that was
fair.
>> How about their families?
Thank you for asking that
question, because it prompted
this
question.  How about their
families?  How did they feel
when
they saw the book or when they
saw the movie?  The families of
these women?
Because it wasn't just the
women.
>> DONNA: We went down to
Hampton to show Katherine
Johnson
the film.
Which is really a nerve wracking
experience.
>> Right.
>> DONNA: You know, you have
her life in your hands, which
you're portraying.
Her two daughters were with her.
She gets
around principally in a
wheelchair.  So we rented out a
movie
theater in Hampton, and her
daughters and she came and
watched
the film.  I mean I was in the
back thinking, "I don't know.  I
don't know."
And then I heard snuffling at
the end.  And there were a lot
of hankies that were being
spread among these three women.
And
that's when I knew we were okay.
And both of her daughters were
very moved by it.
And Katherine, again, I think
she's -- she's
not an overly effusive
personalty, but she approved of
it.  And
it was a big deal.
>> Recording your life like
that.
>> DONNA: Exactly.
>> I want to congratulate you,
Margot, and you, Donna, you
have done wonderful work
bringing these stories to us as
an
audience, as the public.  We
just want more of these stories.
And keep it up.  And
congratulations.
[Applause.]
>> You can find Margot out
there signing books.
And I hope
you will take the opportunity to
meet her and say hello.  Thank
you for something.  Thank you
very much.
[Applause].
>> That was fun.